a week before protests and riots broke
out in American cities as a response to
the police killing of George Floyd
demonstrators were also out in the
streets of Hong Kong police misconduct
is also a major concern in Hong Kong and
activists are demanding an independent
investigation into the city's once
world-renowned police force for its
brutal treatment of the demonstrators
the Hong Kong protests which first
flared up in the fall of 2019 have also
at times turned violent
with property damage and attacks on
innocent bystanders triggered by the
gruesome video of Floyd's murder the
u.s. protests are about the mistreatment
of black Americans by law enforcement
while in Hong Kong the issue is whether
or not this bastion of political and
economic freedom will maintain its
autonomy from the authoritarian Chinese
state the inciting incident last fall
was the introduction of an extradition
law that allowed the Chinese to transfer
fugitives to the mainland and now
China's passage of a national security
law that criminalizes the so called
subversion of state power has incited
the latest round of unrest prompting
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo to tell
Congress that Beijing's actions mean
that Hong Kong is no longer autonomous
from China putting an end to the one
country two systems' that was
established in 1997 when the UK
relinquished control of its former
colony on May 29th President Trump
announced the Hong Kong special partner
trading status would be revoked and that
sanctions are forthcoming China has
replaced its promised formula of one
country two systems' with one country
one system therefore I am directing my
administration to begin the process of
eliminating policy exemptions that give
Hong Kong different and special
treatment days before China's National
People's Congress rubber-stamp the new
law I interviewed Charles Mok a Hong
Kong legislator representing the tech
sector who's part of a pro-democracy
coalition to discuss the impact of the
new law and what will happen if China
sends its own police force into the city
to go head-to-head with protesters it's
now been more than a year out since the
latest protest movement began what is
the on-the-ground feeling in Hong Kong
right now so a lot of frustration on the
one hand
and a lot of anger and a much of it
because of the lack of response from the
government for the whole year with all
these apparent and obvious police
brutality violations and so on going
uninvestigated and the government
refusing to negotiate with us it is
after all the majority real in Hong Kong
for more than two decades that we should
have a more democratic system we're
actually moving farther away from it
recently we had this coronavirus
concerns and outbreak but that is pretty
much fortunately for ourselves and for
the cooperation of our citizens much of
it is under control and we haven't had a
new cases for quite a while local cases
know so in that sense you know the
government cannot use the virus control
as a as an excuse to tell us you know
don't go out don't don't don't have
protests and even any gathering and so
on so some people really are not coming
out as before but I think this doesn't
mean that people are giving up they are
using other means they are turning to
other possible alternatives just like in
last November when a huge number of
people voters turned out was your
unexpected unprecedented voter turnout
in a district level election where how
pro-democracy candidates got 18 more
than 80 percent of the seats at the time
so you could see that people are using
different means what exactly would the
national security law which is being
proposed in Beijing have on hong kong so
they are going to impose a law that
would be a national law but it's about
hong kong and it will impose super super
imposed on hong kong we are expecting it
to be very draconian there going to be a
lot of conflicts between the kind of
chinese law system with the common law
system that we have been practicing in
hong kong in
seen you to practice after the handover
that the global business community would
consider to be more accommodating and
reasonable so this is going to be very
problematic in terms of even some of the
terms that were being proposed would
mean that the central government can
send their national security people
their officers to Hong Kong to execute
the law hmm that would mean that
basically it's not just the Hong Kong
police that we are going to be
confronting it would be a mainland
officers and think about that what is
national security
it doesn't mean shouting one slogan that
the government or central government
doesn't like some people have said that
you know we could even be saying that
you know we should be saying something
against our local Hong Kong government
and that would be considered as part of
the regime of China so that would be
illegal as well if the central
government wanted to de-escalate the
situation rather than you know amp it up
what are some measures that you think
they could realistically take at this
point a thorough investigation and
accountability on our own government
that is I think absolutely the first
step and also there's got to be more
liberalisation in terms of talking about
how to give Hong Kong people more
autonomy in terms of a democratic
election but when I say this the reality
is the central government has already
basically said no to all these things
over the last year and moving farther
and farther away by clamping down and
saying that you cannot even ask for
those things if you do then we consider
you to be a separatist or consider you
to be a calling for independence which I
think most most people in Hong Kong
including myself are only talking about
truly implementing into one country two
systems that we were promised the
unfortunate thing is I think the
solution is there but I cannot
confidentially say that the central
government is going to take up these
steps because the reality is the further
the and the longer they dis is dragged
on and the
further they moved to the other side of
using draconian and drastic measures
it's becoming more and more difficult
for them to move back to the central to
the center to try to take these more
liberal and open mind the steps that
could have solved the problem long time
ago macht was one of several legislators
involved in a disagreement over
committee leadership that devolved into
a physical altercation on the floor of
legislature on May 17th
resulting in the majority of
pro-democracy legislators including MOC
being escorted off the floor by security
MOC says this amounted to another power
grab by the pro-beijing coalition which
because of the peculiarities of Hong
Kong's electoral system holds majority
power in the legislature despite drawing
fewer votes from the public the
situation right now is we are trying to
use every which way we can to try to not
let them legitimize this whole process
but the different is going to become
more and more difficult because the
whole power the whole infrastructure
apparatus is being controlled by the
establishment would you imagine the
security force in the Congress holding
the minority members like let's say in
this case the Republicans in the house
or the other way around the Democrats in
the Senate because they are trying to
filibuster have you ever seen the
security or the or the Congress police
or whatever
Holloman police come out to help the
Chairman take away the the other elected
members as that grip seems to continue
to tighten to the degree that the
minority party is now being forcibly
removed from the legislature for these
unconventional something to pass or
something to pass I mean how like how
does that affect you personally how do
you think about your position in this
party as someone who's obviously been
willing to speak out and be critical do
you ever worry about that are you do you
I think you ever come under any sort of
surveillance or anything of that nature
well I have to say that I think people
in Hong Kong not just on us in the
legislature but but a lot of people even
common citizens are becoming very
concerned about surveillance I mean ever
since last year there were a lot of
concerns about all these cameras all
over the streets because of surveillance
cameras that were supposedly used for
traffic control but then there might be
high-definition and they might be doing
facial recognition of people whether you
join the protest or where you were at
whatever time there are a lot of
concerns about these kind of
surveillance issues and over the last
couple of days ever since the
announcement by the central government
of this national security law I think
there's a huge concern of a lot of
people here that's the internet for
example in the communications over the
internet movie surveillance will be will
be watch over in suddenly everybody
wants to install their own VPN their own
virtual private network to make sure
that you know at least that part of the
communication can be secure a lot of
misconception I have to say technically
but still a lot of people are afraid and
they are resorting dudes to these means
to try to protect themselves as for me
personally I think we're in this
position we have to stand for what we
believe in and we're still just trying
to make sure that we're doing the right
thing the best thing for Hong Kong we
don't want to see everything being
destroyed and we're worried as you
started off saying that you know some
people are asking is it going to be the
end of Hong Kong or the end
one country to a system and the more you
look at it the more light the more is
the more it's like it that this is going
to be the end because how do you turn it
back especially for a regime like
Beijing they are so concerned about you
know losing phase or you know they've
said it that they have to do it so how
could they rescind that is the big
question we obviously would want to make
sure that we urge them in every way we
can
protesters may have their own way we try
other ways but at least we are trying to
send the same message and I hope to the
international community as well that if
this happens it will hurt everyone they
were hurt Hong Kong it will hurt
everyone and it is an international city
who hurts every countries around the
world and if the every country around
the world stand by food stood by for too
long things could lose control and we're
seeing it since last year I would have
hoped that there would be more actions
locally or in China or all the world
over Hong Kong a year ago and maybe we
could have it could have been better but
I don't know I mean right now the
situation is just getting worse and
worse well what are you hoping for from
the world because everyone is looking at
China right now it being the epicenter
of the outbreak the way that was handled
the relationship with the World Health
Organization Hong Kong obviously
surprisingly to a lot of people has
handled it incredibly well and these
you've had very few deaths from
coronavirus there as far as I understand
I I think five so there's been some
belligerent statements coming out of our
politicians from Mike Pompeo and trum
themself
what are your worries about what could
happen internationally and what do you
hope the global community in the United
States in particular does in this
situation well I don't want to be
telling other governments what to do but
I think it should be a legitimate
concerns for all governments for
especially and international city like
Hong Kong because we're after all a
financial center we are a hub for many
important business activities where they
be with not just China but the rest of
Asia is hugely important for global
interest and think about it if we used
to say that this is Hong Kong is 1 2 3
top market trading markets in the world
after London in New York if it gone down
it's not easily going to be replaced by
somebody else it would have huge
implications and I think I hope that
people would also look at it in such a
way that Hong Kong is also a city with 7
million people 7 or 8 million people and
we have a lot of human asset over here
in addition to the financial assets in
that that that people make some foreign
companies foreign interests are trying
to pull out some of these interests
financial interest but there are also a
lot of people over here and we're
talking a lot of people here in Hong
Kong they are going to be subjected to a
regime or kind of rule of a kind of rule
that they were not expecting when we
were handed over to China so what do we
do about these human asset that are we
just saying that too bad you know we we
we we didn't expect this to happen that
we trusted the Chinese government 20 or
more than 20 years ago 30 years ago with
this joint declaration and so on and now
what too bad or what are you going to do
about these people let alone the
economic interest so I think that is the
question that the global community has
to
about I don't want to be here telling
them what to do enough obviously you saw
that there were different politicians in
different countries making different
statements compared or over over the
last couple of days I think the National
Security Advisor O'Brien also has
something to say so I think they would
they would consider their options from
your interest point of view but I think
I hope that they would also think about
it from the from the interest and the
point of view from the people here in
Hong Kong addition to the global
us-china relationship backdrop how do
you expect this to play out for you and
for Hong Kong over the next few years
it's very difficult to predict but I
think the lesson since last year in Hong
Kong
is that we probably have to prepare for
the worst
because you know I if you ask me two
months ago or even two weeks ago if we
expected this so a sudden and abrupt
announcement saying that they will
legislate in Beijing and overruling Hong
Kong you know I would still be saying is
it going to happen
Tibbits I doubt it if you asked me two
weeks ago so things are getting worse
and worse
a out of I would say out really out
about my or many people's most people's
expectation so I think looking forward
we have to be prepared for the worst
like I said the the legislation of the
bill in Beijing and then they working
out the details and then maybe pretty
soon and actually they've said it in
Beijing that they would probably enact
and execute on the law possibly to
arrest a few people or I don't know what
a few means some people to make an
example to make sure that if they
legislates law if they don't use it
what's the point
right so to a dictatorship obviously
they would do that so they will use the
lord they'll put some people in jail
whether they be in jail in Hong Kong
sent back to China we don't know and it
will get worse some people look at the
September election of our legislature my
view is that and I think the majority
view here the worry is that they will
use a lot of means to disqualify
manipulate the result of the real action
which means that if they think that you
are going to get elected they may just
disqualifies you from standing from the
beginning and then if you still some if
some other people still get elected and
there are too many of us they will
disqualify you so then to make sure
which they have been doing the last step
in this term currently and so even
though we are talking about alcam is
praise has been advocating voter
registration or that to tell people that
we need to win the majority but deep
down if you ask me am I worried is that
I'm sure it Beijing it's not going to
let it happen so but we do have to tell
the people to vote right as it only
means they have to express themselves
now but the worry is that we are going
to win the majority but they will
disqualify us during nomination and
after the election to make sure that we
are still a small minority in order to
continue to make sure the legislature is
a rubber stamp
so my outlook my expectation on that
which is going to be just a few months
down the road for us if my view is
pretty dark on that
I mean how worried are you about this
turning like seriously violence given
there's a very entrenched resistance to
this and I'm just imagining the
prospects of China sending their own you
know police force yeah yeah that's a big
worry because there are obviously a
bunch of very agitated and aggressive
and frustrated young people among the
protesters that are using relatively
mobile in tactics in Hong Kong in the
last couple
so even yesterday and my biggest worry
is that this will be definitely used as
an excuse by the authority to turn up
the heat again in such a situation I
think any reasonable Liberal government
would understand that you know pure
force would not be the solution they are
you know if there is a riot I mean do
you send even in the u.s. in Los Angeles
right do you send even more troops to
put everybody in jail does that solve
the problem your experience told you
that there are other ways to really do
it in to to resolve the problem right
but in here the I am worried that these
kinds of so-called violence on the side
of the protesters it's just going to
give them more excuse to legislate in
even more draconian way to enforce in
even more draconian ways to try to send
in mainland forces to execute in Hong
Kong where they be to arrest people or
to act against the protesters and so on
so my worry is that is going to get
worse so I think I do hope that the
Western audience will look at this in
such a way that you know think about
what cost what's the cost of the whole
conflict and not just individual acts of
violence which we don't want to see but
unfortunately if the two sides are going
to be food farther and farther apart we
have to ask for those people who are in
authority position the government can
you just simply blame the people for
being violent I think it I mean if you
put it in the context of many of these
conflicts or even riots in the u.s. you
would have
probably hopefully come to the same
conclusion it must be something wrong
that the government have been doing and
not just blaming the people who may have
conducted acts of violence it must be
the government's also or even the root
of the blame yeah it didn't come from
nowhere that's for sure
and I think our audience understands
that and it's following this with great
interest and I really appreciate you
filling us in and giving us this kind of
on-the-ground report it was very
insightful so thank you for your time
thank you
[Music]